you
yeah
[Music]
I'll come hide over here good
- thanks tomorrow
have fun yeah it should be around 6:15
Temari absolutely little work and then
Friday you just get to hang out
great that's such a diss you know people
from the mainland think the shop in
Hawaii
[Music]
yeah
it's just
then she says
over there
[Music]
yes
okay make sure it's either turned on or
ever thought of rain
yeah
the negative x-axis
[Music]
yeah
because today's
and I don't want to reach out
oh really
wonderful things
to train
by the way
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats and silence your cellphone's the
program is about to begin
there is no academic institution that is
more qualified and better positioned to
lead the charge around the impact of
technology on society and Carnegie
Mellon
[Music]
as technology is ever advancing our
lives we must be mindful of the human
toll and determined that technology and
policy must together be a force for good
and prosperity for all
[Music]
the Carnegie Mellon University block
Center for technology and society deeply
passionate and fiercely dedicated to
this work welcome ladies and gentlemen
to a dedication to shared prosperity a
celebration of the block's Center for
technology and society please give a
warm welcome to the 10th president of
Carnegie Mellon University dr. Farnham
Jahan Ian
[Applause]
thank you very much and good afternoon
what a fabulous video don't you agree
do these lights come on I have to be
able to read my notes I guess they don't
Keith's first of all I want to tell you
that if you haven't been outside we
ordered some vintage Pennsylvania
Pittsburgh weather for you just in case
you forgot the weather here and you're
not in California so you're welcome on
behalf of the entire leadership team I'm
pleased to welcome all of you to this
afternoon's program a celebration of the
exciting work being done at the block
Center for technology and society at
Carnegie Mellon we announced the launch
of the center as you know about a year
ago and thanks to the extraordinary
generosity of our trustee our alum and
co-ceo of Salesforce Keith block and his
wife Susan Kelly
today of course we're delighted to have
Keith with us to celebrate the center's
vision or a dedication to shared
prosperity Keith welcome back to campus
also would like to extend a special
welcome to several of our trustees who
are here with us including our chair Jim
roar of course Alex de Claudio is here
at Frank was here I saw him Brian Craig
is here Jack McGrath as I mentioned Jim
roar and Luke's Kerman welcome back to
campus I'm also grateful and thankful to
Ramaiah Krishnan our Dean of Heinz
College of information systems and
Public Policy whose leadership energy
has helped make Keith's bold vision a
reality
Krishnan thank you so much for your
efforts for your leadership and
everything you have done to make CMU
successful and can of course this Center
successful
I should note and I was told that I
needed to make sure that I mentioned us
to embarrass Krishna and it's Krishna's
birthday happy birthday Krishna
we won't sing you have your birthday now
maybe we'll embarrass you at lunchtime
instead so what will we'll get to that
later finally I want to acknowledge an
important member of CMU community and
the block center leadership team
professor Raul tell on Raul as I'm sure
most of you know is recovering from a
very serious accident and we miss him
here today Raul I know you'll be
probably be watching this presentation
at some point please know that you and
your family are in our thoughts and we
look forward to your return back to
campus today we're at the center of a
societal and economic transformation
that is catalyzed by unprecedented
access and advances to technology these
advances are accelerating the pace of
discovery across all fields of inquiry
and transforming almost every sector of
our economy from healthcare to
transportation to energy production and
distribution to defense to manufacturing
and yes also education in particular the
growing power and impact of artificial
intelligence is perhaps the most
important intellectual development of
our time but it's development also has
important implications for society in
terms of ethics policy and privacy and
many other aspects of our society
Carnegie Mellon I'm sure you agree is
uniquely positioned to take the lead in
it in this critical domain as the
university that has been intimately
involved in the creation of some of
these most transformative technologies
we've definitely been responsible for
some of the remarkable innovations over
the past few decades but even as we
break new ground in this new technology
we also recognize the importance of
bringing interdisciplinary teams
together to understand
manage and at times to mitigate the
impact of technology on society at CMU
scientist engineers work together with
philosophers artists and economists who
will shape what might be possible with
ethicist v humanist and policy expert
who will guide our path and of course
with behavioural scientist who will
measure the impact of work on humanity
Keith and Susan had an ambitious vision
to make the most of our strengths they
saw how important is the core core
strengths that we have is here and how
we could intentionally harness this
interdisciplinary culture to ensure that
our inventions elevate our ingenuity to
are our inventions elevate our ingenuity
inspires and our dedication to shared
prosperity is felt across the globe
thanks to their generosity of course the
block Center has brought new momentum to
CMU's leadership at the Nexus of
Technology and society in just a few
minutes we're going to hear from a few
colleagues about the progress that we've
made at this Center however in the
meantime I want to thank again Keith for
his generosity and also were profoundly
grateful to him and to Susan for their
generosity and for their commitment to
our institution thanks to your
generosity Keith CMU is helping to shape
the world in ways that could not have
been seen possible even a few years ago
especially at the Nexus of policy and
technology at this moment I want to
invite Keith to join me at the podium
and share via few thoughts with us
ladies and gentlemen please extend a
warm welcome to Keith block
Thank You Farnum good morning everybody
uh I just want to apologize in case you
can't hear it in my voice I'm suffering
from you can fill in the blank I'm
suffering from something any my my wife
Suzanne would have loved to have
attended we actually flipped a coin this
morning she also has what I have but she
is she is back in the hotel
unfortunately but she wishes all of you
well I'm very very appreciative Farnum
front for your kind words and your
support is always in your friendship
you've been wonderful and always
inspirational to me and obviously
Krishnan a great friend and
inspirational as well and I want to
thank the trustees that are here and the
students and the faculty of the
University for your inspiration as many
of you know I graduated back in 1984
from then the school of herb the school
of urban and public affairs now Heinz
and also getting my undergraduate degree
in information systems and I always
thought this was a really cool idea
where you could bring information
systems to public policy or bring
technology to public policy obviously
for over 30 years I did not practice
that but I had a passion for it when I
started my career at Booz Allen I was
advising senior executives on the use of
technology but never around public
policy and then going on to Oracle
Corporation for 26 years
it was the same same sort of thing and
Here I am at Salesforce and it's
Salesforce having the opportunity to
meet with world leaders senior
executives from all walks of life from
every company shape size industry all
over the world and my wife Suzanne who
has spent over 25 years at Oracle always
in the technology industry she as well
has had the opportunity to work with
this technology see the impact of
technology in society and this has been
percolating in our heads for a very very
long time about what technology will
bring to the world and what the impact
of technology will bring to
world and then of course there's this
thing called children and when you have
five kids and I'm sure many of your
parents you think about what is the
world that we will bestow upon our
children
what will they inherit from us what have
we done would have been our decisions
both in the public and private sector
that will impact their world and and
while this was all percolating in our
heads I distinctly remember a
conversation three years ago in a
trustees meeting at this incredible
university and sitting down with Krishna
and talking about Heinz and policy and
the intersection of policy and
technology and you know we have this
thing called the fourth Industrial
Revolution which we all talked about you
know fourth Industrial Revolution had
this buzzword feel to it just like
digital transformation and artificial
intelligence and if we took a poll of
everybody in this room we'd probably get
a different answer about what those
three things really are and I remember
at the World Economic Forum just a few
years ago people would walk around
saying oh yes digital transformation and
they would shake their heads and nobody
had any idea what that was and here we
are in this world that we live in I mean
the fourth Industrial Revolution it's
here you know it's this perfect storm
this convergence in technology where you
have cloud and mobile and social and
data science and you know IOT has been
around for a long time but we have
blockchain and we have quantum computing
and 3d printing and artificial
intelligence as fernand talked about and
all of these things have come together
at a pace and scale that is
unprecedented in the history of the
world this is not the first the second
or third Industrial Revolution this is
very different this time and this is
concussive waves coming on the shore and
how does society absorb this technology
because it is created a world of disrupt
or be disrupted where business models
are changing every day where markets are
created and markets are failing and this
is happening at such a rapid pace that
it is and will continue to have a
profound impact on our society and in
that conversation with with Krishnan
three years ago the question was what
can do what could Susan and I do we are
blessed we are grateful for being in the
position
having you know very nice careers and
having a great family and friends and
living a good life but what was our way
of giving it back to the society and
because of the passion that I personally
have for this university because I think
it is unlike any University in the world
on so many fronts
just an incredible school this was a way
to actually bring together the public
sector in the private sector to bring
together amazing thought leadership to
change the world by thinking about
policy and technology and how does the
how do these two worlds collide you know
we live in a world today where some
people would say that we have a trust
crisis or a trust deficit trust in our
governments trust in our institutions
trust in our leadership and how do we
fill that breach what do we do we see
CEOs taking position historically they
never would have taken around public
policy I mean look at what's happened
with Salesforce its Salesforce a few
years back we took a very very strong
position on the rights of LGBTQ in
Indiana because we felt it was the right
thing to do because the action that then
Governor Pence was taken was
inconsistent with our values because we
wanted to protect our employees last
summer we had a situation where our
employees were questioning the ethical
use of our technology that was being
deployed by Seabee at the borders last
year we also had a situation where our
employees use their voice because
transparency in a culture is very very
important about using our technology to
help online guns gun stores sell guns
with our e-commerce engine interestingly
enough that was right around the time
where we had the horrible shooting here
in Pittsburgh in fact I was here during
that period of time visiting with my son
just that weekend but these are the
issues that we have to tackle the
ethical use of technology the disruption
in the workforce what is the future of
work how is this two being applied is
this a force for good is it personally
and very positive about this I'm pretty
much a glass half-full person but I
believe this is an opportunity to bring
the know-how the
leadership the creativity the innovation
of this university together with the
private sector and the public sector
three great forces to drive good around
the use of technology access to
technology which brings opportunity to
all for all creativity around education
there are so many issues issues that
need to be addressed and need to be
tackled that can provide a greater world
not the doom and gloom that we hear
about the dark cloud of the fourth
Industrial Revolution but a force for
positive technology is a good thing if
applied the right way if used in an
ethical manner and if used creatively
but it will require excuse me a public
and private partnership and that is so
important and that's why I believe the
Center for technology and society is so
important because it is an opportunity
to do something where we can bring these
three forces together the public sector
the private sector and the leading
academic institution in the world in my
opinion so that was the inspiration for
the Center for Science and Technology
and Suzanne and I couldn't be more
thrilled to be part of this and to work
with all of you and your interest has
been fantastic and when we appreciate it
your inspiration continues every single
day about what this Center can do and I
hope it has a very very bright future
but that bright future will be based on
you and your contributions and your
passion for this topic and believe me
this is a passion a topic that we should
all have passion for so Farnum I want to
say thank you so much for your support
in Christian on your support as well on
the rest of the board and all the folks
at CMU really really appreciate it and
we're looking for great things out of
this institution thank you so much
[Music]
and now introducing the Dean of the
Heinz College of information systems and
public policy doctor Ramaiah Krishnan
thank you
Thank You Keith Thank You Suzanne
Keith thank you once again for your
leadership it's been a real pleasure
working with you and with Farnham to
make this a reality and I'm so proud of
this journey that we have begun here and
this initiative is really taking shape
it's gaining momentum due to the great
work of so many of my faculty colleagues
who are here with us today and I want to
thank Farnum for his leadership of the
university and for making technology
humanity in society the nexus of these
topics a really important strategic
priority at the University thank you so
before we begin the talks from my
colleagues on earth I'd like to set the
stage for what you're about to hear so
Keith spoke about what inspired him to
support this initiative and I'd like to
describe how you're turning his
inspiration into into reality what work
we will do and how we'll ensure that we
are successful but I should also take a
moment to say that we've been really
overwhelmed by the response from every
one of you when we sent this invitation
out for this dedication to shared
prosperity event and I want to welcome
everybody including all the trustees and
I see Maximus here as well so thank you
so much for being here being so
responsive to this event so when I think
about the the research at the center and
how it's going to be organized good he
organized around three big interrelated
ideas not siloed but interrelated ideas
the first is that AI LED disruption that
will affect human work in in many ways
some predictable
some that are uncertain but these are
topics that were interested in studying
in detail so that we can educate both
policymakers and business leaders on
what they will face and how we can
actually dampen the human toll
associated with this potential
disruption we're also interested in what
happens at the juncture of human and
machine what skills will be necessary
who will be left behind and what new
opportunities will emerge are some of
the three important questions we'd like
to address and then this first idea we
call the future of work the second idea
is one that sort of really is
cross-cutting but we think of that as
broadly a I for social good and the idea
here is that much of the technology that
is likely going to cause disruption is
really being birthed clears being
invented here we have outstanding social
scientists ethicists philosophers and
our boundary-less culture at this
university means that they can work side
by side with the engineers and computer
scientists so that when the technology
is being invented these concepts these
ideas are built into the technology then
just rather having the social scientists
and the philosophers and the editors
just react to technological change so
there's this idea of being involved
right at the front end is an important
part this is important because even if
you are able to invent AI that uplifts
humanity adoption is still not ensured
because there are important issues and I
think both Farnam and Keith spoke about
this important issues related to
fairness bias Trust that have to be
addressed we have already made
considerable progress here at CMU and
will continue to make progress in this
area and by convening and educating
policymakers and business leaders we
really hope to have an impact in this
important domain and adoption and future
of work will go hand-in-hand
something that differentiates CMU from
so many other excellent universities
that are engaged in this topic is our
attitude it's our research culture our
focus on solving real problems and
taking on issues that will have societal
impact while making fundamental and
foundational contributions to science
really sets us apart so you've heard me
often talk about a culture of research
development and deployment what we call
Rd and D and the block Center is no
different so our success here will hinge
on our ability to test in the real world
answers to some of these questions by
having these deep partnerships with
organizations so if you will the ideas
to really embed or plant solutions in
organizational partner testbeds
there's an idea that I call seeding
societal futures and through a
commitment to these partnerships with
organizations we learn more we will
build more and ultimately we'll be able
to help more and the objective here is
to really harness the innovation and
innovative culture of CMU to alleviate
human suffering but also provide
economic opportunity so those are the
three big ideas future of work a I for
social gird and seeding societal futures
and at this point I'd like to sort of
turn this over to my colleagues were
going to be speaking Tom Mitchell a true
pioneer in machine learning is the lead
technologist at the block Center he will
describe the current state of Technology
in his talk entitled how a AI changes
work and what we should do about it
after that
professor Havilland a leading
statistician who leads our AI for social
good initiative will give us an example
of human and AI collaboration and the
problems that arise and why it's really
important to overcome them in her talk
entitled AI when the stakes are high and
finally professor Branstetter a
prominent economist who leads our future
of work initiative will extend the theme
of human in AI collaboration and discuss
a project entitled can a I make
education great again
so these talks
these talks taken together signify the
deep challenges we face but importantly
also the justified optimism that we
share about the future and Carnegie
Mellon's role in it and I think you'll
see why we are super excited about the
potential at the block Center for
technology and society so without
further ado I hope you enjoy the program
thank you introducing our first
presenter dr. Tom Mitchell and his talk
how a eye changes work and what we
should do about it
thank you I I just want to start by
saying what a delight it is to be here
today as part of this celebration and to
be a participant in the block Center on
I want to talk about AI where it's
headed and the kinds of impacts that can
have and what we might be able to do
about it
I didn't bring a clicker so it's going
to be harder to give my time thank you
technology so if we want to talk about
AI I think the very best way to begin is
to think about the ways in which really
we've seen very dramatic progress in AI
over the past 10 years it's hard to
recall because we get so used to the
technology but if you think back to the
year 2007 when the iPhone came out to
remember that you could not talk to the
iPhone it's hard to believe since we
talked to our devices all the time now
you could not talk to your iPhone
because computers were deaf computers
did not speech recognition did not work
but today a little bit over 10 years
later computer technology for speech
recognition has reached roughly the
level of humans and transcribing spoken
speech to the equivalent written form
and here's the plot showing the advance
in speech recognition
accuracy over the years similarly ten
years ago computers were not only deaf
they were blind you could show them a
photograph and they were unable to
accurately recognize the items in that
photograph but again here are 10 years
later we have computers that can
identify thousands of objects in
standard photographs again now with
accuracies that rival human level in the
area of Robotics we see similar progress
10 years ago we didn't have on the
streets of Pittsburgh autonomous
vehicles driving ground very frequently
we had a few PhD theses in the early
nineties but now it's a routine thing
and it's not even just uber it's several
companies here in Pittsburgh on beyond
self-driving cars we see the advent of
robotics and medical surgery and and
many other arenas so you might ask
yourself well let me point out one other
area in the area of game playing
computers have famously beat the best
human at go at chess more recently
thanks to Thomas and Holmes work here at
poker and you might think well it's kind
of a frivolity to think about AI in game
playing but it's not it turns out that
the fact that AI can beat us all in
these kind of games is the symptom of a
very different kind of intelligence than
is required for perception for hearing
or for seeing because to win at a game
you have to think analytically about
look ahead search probabilistic outcomes
what if I draw a queen and you have to
do a very different kind of reason so
across several different very disparate
areas we've seen dramatic advances and
artificial intelligence and the reason
we've seen those I have to say is
because there's been an underlying
paradigm shift in the way in which
artificial intelligence is being driven
we've changed from the days when people
try to manually write programs
to do these kinds of things too instead
we're dominantly people are training
using machine learning programs to do
these so that's kind of where the
technology is I just wanted to kind of
refresh our minds because we forget
often how quickly this is advancing over
the coming ten years I think we'll see
even more rapid advances so what are the
impacts of this and what can we do about
it
I had the good fortune of co-chairing of
recently a National Academy study on
information technology and the US
workforce and in that study we looked at
and considered a variety of types of
impacts and the main conclusion of the
study is that this is a complex
situation and there are many different
types of impact that information
technology is exerting on the workforce
and I want to list those here the first
and most obvious one is on jobs of
course for example there are jobs that
are going to be eliminated by technology
there's no doubt about it if you are a
tollbooth operator your job will be
eliminated in the coming decade it's
it's easier and more efficient to do
that with technology and it's already
happening it will happen more but there
are other kinds of jobs and as we looked
more and more into this in the national
academy study and in some follow-up
research i've been doing in
collaboration with Erik Brynjolfsson at
an economist at MIT we found that in
fact it looks to us like most jobs will
not be eliminated but most jobs will be
impacted and here's kind of the quick
explanation of why think about the job
of a doctor well the doctors job be
eliminated by technology I think the
answer is no but it'll be dramatically
changed so the way to think about this
is if you're a doctor
unlike Tollbooth operator your job
involves many tasks you have to diagnose
the patient you have to come up with
candidate therapies you have to discuss
with that patient which of those
therapies they really elect to proceed
with and you have to build a patient so
those are some of the tasks involved and
when you think about automation the
right way to think about it is it
applies not to the whole job at once but
to those individual tasks so we did a
study using the Bureau of Labor
Statistics taxonomy of jobs and the
affiliated tasks and what our study
indicated was that in fact most jobs
like the doctor involve multiple tasks
most of those jobs will have at least
some tasks influenced augmented or
perhaps automated by technology but most
jobs will not be eliminated because
there will remain other tasks that are
not going to be amenable to automation
in the near term so for example a doctor
I think that jobs not going away but in
the future we could expect that doctors
will receive more aid from computers for
diagnosis and therapy generation
probably not more aid from computers for
having the heart-to-heart chat with the
patient about what to do and so that's
that was that's kind of the good or the
bad news for us I think many jobs will
be impacted in fact our studies show
that the majority of jobs will be but in
fact rather than being eliminated
they'll be redefined by redistributing
those tasks so that's one kind of impact
second kind of impact is on education
both the supply and the demand for
education one way to think about that is
in terms of when what and how we teach
so today at Carnegie Mellon we typically
teach undergraduates for four years and
send them on their way
but in the world where
there's more dynamism in the ebb and
flow of different types of jobs clearly
we're going to want more and more
continuing education so that's the wind
part the what part what do we want to
educate people to do what do we want to
teach and here again it looks like we
want maybe we need to do a little less
teaching of rote memorization effects
but we might need to do a little bit
more teaching of the emotional
intelligence associated skills skills
for forming teams dynamically for
collaborating in those teams with people
who know things you don't and vice versa
and assembling dynamic teams to solve
the problem at hand so that's the when
and the what the how is also going to be
impacted already you can see on the
internet a huge explosion over the last
decade in online educational materials
but it's going to go beyond that it
won't be just in the distribution of
education materials it'll be in the
actual content and my colleague Lee is
going to talk a little bit more later on
specifically how AI might enter into
computer tutoring systems to change even
the how of how teaching is done
a third area for impact is business
models as Keith mentioned in his remarks
a moment ago technology is just
introducing whole new ways of doing
business one of the most obvious here is
the gig economy uber lyft but not just
that that level of skill there are other
gig economy jobs for example up work is
a gig economy company that matches up
freelance programmers computer
programmers to available computer
programming jobs and this is I think a
wonderful development a key development
for the future of the workforce for two
reasons one it brings into the workforce
people who might not be able for
personal reasons to work 40 hours a week
they can work when they want where they
want the second reason is that that this
is so important to us is that it
provides an alternative to people who
lose their job instead of going on the
unemployment lines the turnit --iv
option of working and in the gig economy
while they look for a new position in
fact I read in the news that during the
recent government shutdown there were
government employees who took advantage
of uber and lyft became drivers
part-time during that shutdown so that
could be an important part of providing
alternative employment opportunities and
yet another impact is unfortunately on
the wealth gap as as we all know there
is a very strong skew in the
distribution of income and wealth in the
United States sadly it looks like
technology is exacerbating that one way
to think about that is that many of the
technology companies that are software
companies for example can produce more
wealth with fewer people why
compare that with say Ford Motor Company
which produces automobiles they're the
marginal cost if you're going to produce
one more automobile and sell that you
have to have employees to to make the
next copy of an automobile you have to
have hire other people to transport that
automobile to the point of sale you have
to have repair shops out there that keep
it running if instead you're producing a
piece of software the marginal cost for
the next copy of software is
approximately zero you hit the copy
button the marginal cost for
transporting that around the world
copies of that and selling it is
approximately zero you put it on the
Apple Store the Google Play Store and
tomorrow morning everybody in the world
can access it so that's another impact
so what can we do about this well the
good news is there are several things we
can do
there are several things the government
can do and there are several things that
we not in the government can do for
example the government can adopt
policies to foster a stronger gig
economy so that people who are
temporarily unemployed have an
opportunity to still have a job while
they're rebounding what does it mean to
foster a gig economy well one key
component of that is to make to remove
the disincentives for employees for
people to join that gig economy
currently people who work in the gig
economy don't feign benefits that have
if we work 40-hour weeks they don't have
health care benefits they don't have
vacations they don't have retirement
plans government policies can change
that a second thing the government can
do is incentivize continuing education I
just learned this week in fact that in
Denmark when you work you accrue not
only vacation days but you also accrue
continuing education credits that you
can use to upskill yourself and
furthermore if you change jobs you keep
those continuing education credits they
travel with you so there's their policy
options there a third area of public
private data partnerships the sad news
is we are flying blind into the jobs
revolution we don't really have the data
we need to track what's really going on
in the economy we the Bureau of Labor
Statistics cannot answer very
fundamental questions like what
technology had the most impact on the
workforce last year
we don't know the answer to that and yet
if you think about it you think about
the data that's actually online beyond
the government in places like indeed.com
job sites on the web in places like
linkedin calm resume sits on the web
then you see that those datasets
actually could provide us a real-time
updated everyday
here at estimate of skills supply and
demand and job supply and demand in the
workforce the Bureau of Labor Statistics
could decide to set up a new kind of
public private data partnerships to give
us all to give the government but then
to disseminate to all of us information
about what's really going on in fact the
OECD in Europe does the best job I've
seen so far they collect from every
country in Europe information about job
supply and demand there and then they
expose that on a beautiful website that
I encourage you to take a look at and if
you look at that website you can see for
example that in Romania there's a
surplus of mathematically trained
individuals and yet in the Netherlands
there's a shortage interesting
information to know if you happen to be
unemployed in Romania so these are
things that the government there are
many things the government can do we can
also do things as technologists and
Emilia is going to speak about this more
in a moment but let me just give you one
example think about what it means to
become to be given a teammate in your
job and think about what that means in
the case that your teammate is a
computer instead of a person if your
teammate is a computer like my doctor
was railing at me recently because he
has to have a computer as a teammate if
your teammate is a computer the computer
is comes with a fixed interface a fixed
set of functionality and you the human
are the one who was expected to
customize and accommodate to the
computer so you the human are the one
who is expected to be the teammate who
adjusts to the other what if we work on
technology that allows the human
teammate to instruct the computer about
how it can help the person I'll just
mention one example we have a project
going on here
at CMU where we're all teammates with
our phones our mobile phones so we have
a project going on to look at the
question of how can we build phone
interfaces so that the human can teach
the phone new capabilities and in our
prototype system you can say to our
phone anytime that it snows at night
wake me up 30 minutes earlier and the
phone responds by saying I don't
understand do you want to teach me and
then you can say yes you can say if you
want to know if it's snowing open up
this weather app and where it says print
conditions if that says Sno W it's
snowing if you want to wake me up 30
minutes earlier open up this alarm app
subtract 13 from that number right there
and after you instructed by showing and
telling it is capable then you've
programmed it you've programmed it not
in a programming language but in your
language and it's just a prototype at
this point but you if you think about
that you get the idea of we're not
helpless in this evolution there are
things we can do both at the government
level and at the technology development
level to change the ways in which people
are going to live and have a having have
the glass half full half of the story
and technology
so to summarize the bottom line is that
information technology has many impacts
on the workforce the good news is there
are things we can do about it both at
the government policy level but also at
the technology development level and the
block Center I'd say is just a great
forum a great substrate for thank you
introducing our second presenter dr.
Amelia Havilland and her talk AI when
the stakes are high technology is
advancing by leaps and bounds we all
know this and some of this has been able
by some of our colleagues right here at
Carnegie Mellon some of them are in the
room even from the school of computer
science from engineering from robotics
that sort of thing
and many of us enjoy some benefits from
these advances based on what they can
help us do like get to work on time when
it snows however there is a flip side to
this which is that the rewards the
economic rewards of these advances so
far have mostly gone to those at the
very top of the economic ladder is where
those advances that where those gains
have gone so far and in fact social
scientists have identified these
technological advances in in hard in
various kinds of technology including
artificial intelligence and machine
learning as one of the key drivers for
the stark increase in inequality and
income inequality that we've all
experienced over the last couple decades
along with the fallout of that
inequality so in this figure you can see
that blue line is showing those at the
top of the ladder this is the top 1% of
Learner of earners and the share of all
income that they've been getting over
time and we can see that going sharply
up and commensurately at the bottom the
bottom 50% of earners that's the red
line is falling over that same time
period
so maybe we shouldn't be too surprised
that at first these technological
advances are going to be put to work for
the benefit of those at the top but here
at the block Center we're focused on
shaping what comes next by investigating
emerging opportunities to put AI and
other technologies to work for all of
our benefits in this talk I'm going to
focus on one of these emerging
opportunities and dive into it some with
you all we're going to be looking at how
AI can be put to work for some of the
most vulnerable among us for children
who are facing abuse and neglect so
what's the connection between AI and
this vulnerable group of children the
connections going to come through the
main way that people report suspected
abuse and neglect which is phone
hotlines so let's look into these lot
hotlines so who's working here in these
hotlines it tends to be social workers
these are highly trained skilled workers
who have graduate degrees and let's
think now about their bundle of tasks
and how AI has some opportunities to
help in a high-stakes situation so there
are two main ways that AI tends to come
in and interact with our tasks one is
that the AI can come in and take a task
out into the AI world and fully
accomplish it so that task is removed
from our bundles and our job gets
reconfigured the other way this tends to
happen is that the AI comes in and sits
next to us here at work and it tries to
help with a task that we are still
owning that's what I'm going to focus on
here is when the AI comes in
so let's dive in and take a close look
at these tasks I'm going to ask you to
imagine that you are the person picking
up the phone here at this at this
hotline okay so here we all are
we're sitting there waiting and is a
high volume these tend to be quite high
volume hotlines phone rings we pick up
the phone here's the story that we hear
the caller is a neighbor they're calling
about concerns about the family next
door that family has been there for
several years that the neighbor knows
the kids to say hi to friendly family
here's what just happened
that made them want to call is that the
two youngest kids came over to the to
the caller's house knocked on the door
and asked to come in when the kids had
never nobody in the family had ever been
over inside the house before and there
were some things off the kids were
dressed really oddly they're wearing
layers and layers of inside clothes and
they were acting really differently than
they had acted before they were really
quiet I seemed scared so a little while
later that the dad came by and seemed to
have not known where the kids were it
seemed worried about that and seemed
pretty distracted and so took the kids
and left and the caller says you know
I'm not sure if I should be making this
call to you to this hotline but
something is not right we need help okay
that's the call part of our task now we
move to the decision making part of our
task we have a decision to make here
about whether with this family to scream
them in screen them in to receiving
Protective Services okay so we are we
have then made the decision that these
children are likely at risk they are
likely in need of protection we are
going to engage these services and there
are further decisions to make about how
urgent that need is okay in next 20
minutes next hour
well how urgent or we can decide to
screen this family out so typically
that's because we've decided that this
family had some other need that the
children didn't need additional
protection there's something else going
on here
like maybe this famil
I was having a hard time paying their
heating bills okay and so what we can do
is provide information about that
program to them meet that need and
stream them out of these protective
services so these are our decisions most
of the time we're highly trained experts
and we get it right right the kids who
are in need of protection get that
protection the families that had other
needs get routed in that direction and
it works fine but not always we are not
going to be perfect about doing this and
this is where there starts to be an
opening to ask the question could a I
come in and help and we need to really
look at what is the nature of the ways
in which we're not able to do as well as
we want to understand where AI could
come in and how it could or couldn't be
helpful what are the pitfalls that could
happen so let's look at the ways those
cook overall so we could make that
choice just reading the family out and
we could be wrong so this is clearly
something we want to avoid these are
children who will need to be protected
we got a call that they needed help and
we did not provide aunt that protection
that's one way I can go wrong but it
also can go wrong the other way which is
that we screen them in and if it turns
out that those children didn't need
protection and we spritz bring them in
it's not only an inefficient allocation
of resources there's also a burden for
that family part of this is that they
get investigated this is an invasive
investigation it's often ever serial
between the family and the people doing
the investigation this is always
stressful for the adults that were
involved and the children tend to be
confused and possibly frightened so
their burdens with that error as well
both directions these are are high
stakes in this situation so we want to
think here about why is it that we are
not always able to reach our goal the
goal is accurate this is
and fair decisions very clear here what
our goal is so what are the things on
the human side that are making us fall
short of being able to get there so one
of the things that's true is that we get
this call we get this new information
and we have to decide how to interpret
it what would really help with that is
background information so let's say for
instance we had some background
information that the night before this
family next door there was a call to the
police about a domestic disturbance oh
that has a strong influence on the way
that we interpret this call that just
came in to us today so we can expand on
that in all kinds of directions and some
child protective service agencies in the
US have taken large steps in this
direction
they've started making connections
between those facilities that are set up
for the call center and all kinds of
additional databases not just police
records but school records for the kids
are they attending school was this
family attached to any services for
homeless families it was better there
been any unemployment file for this
family on and on so now there's this big
information connection and retrieval
task that's going on the more salient
information we can get the better our
decisions are going to be we're going to
get better accuracy if we can make these
connections this is a quite active area
in the field of AI and machine learning
this is unstructured data in lots of
different settings and we need to pull
out only the salient stuff thank you
very much okay time stamps the order of
things matters okay so here are a bunch
of opportunities for us to help improve
accuracy okay that's one way that humans
could use some help here and in doing a
slightly better job I also mentioned
this issue of fairness so here's our
human being overwhelmed by a data
so I also talked a little bit about
fairness
so we also don't want certain
communities of kids some subpopulations
of kids to disproportionately wind up
not receiving help they needed it and
the other way around we don't want some
subpopulations of families to
disproportionately bear the burden of
being investigated when there was no
need for that investigation so why does
this happen for humans if the human is
doing the siding why does this happen
when the humans are committed to doing
this fairly and they are a well-trained
highly trained so again social and
behavioral slaves comes in and helps us
understand what are the ways that people
well intentioned aware people still end
up exhibiting biases and we know a lot
about this actually so for instance we
know that people are sensitive to what's
called recency bias so let's say that we
all knew when we were manning those
phones that yesterday there was a case
that was screened in write services were
sent right out there was a big
investigation and it was not needed
actually and it went really badly we as
humans are likely to respond to that by
overcompensating today it's a systemic
way in which our decision-making can be
off another thing that there's a good
evidence about is that many of us all of
us most likely have some implicit bias
that most of the time we don't act on
but if we're in what's called a heated
emotional state right I have time
urgency here I just got this call from
somebody who's pretty agitated and wants
me to do something all this stuff adds
up to our likely being in a somewhat
heated emotional state evidence shows we
are more likely to act on our implicit
biases when we're in a heated motional
state these are the kinds of things that
we can learn about ways that decision
making by humans can go wrong that maybe
hey I can help with I emphasized the
maybe there there's been an explosion of
research about fairness
nai in the last couple of years there
are very interesting groundbreaking
things that are going on in that area
and we have barely scratched the surface
of thinking about the implications of
all of that research for actually using
AI to help with ways in which humans
tend to make biased decisions there's a
lot of opportunity here for us to help
make fairer decisions okay so a lot of
this stuff is actually being used we
have a great local partner at the block
Center the Allegheny County Department
of Health and Human Services which is
way above ahead of the curve
thank you just some Hinds alumni for
being part of getting this agency so far
ahead of the curve in connecting all
these databases and being one of the
first places to start using AI as part
of this this decision-making at call
centers some articles New York Times
that kind of thing so let's play this
out again here we are we just got off
the call we hang up the phone I know we
don't do it that way anymore and then we
hit a button which is that I've input
all of the information from that call
and what do I know about what that AI is
doing over there right I kind of know
that it's going out to all those data
sources and it's pulling stuff and it
thinks is salient out of those data
sources and it is stuffing all that
stuff into this okay it's smashing all
that all that info into this black box
I'm sitting there pondering this phone
call that I just got right and that box
box what's going on in there is super
clever and super fast and what it does
is it spits out a risk score for me so
here we are sitting here
and we just got this one additional
piece of information which is a risk
score this is a place where a whole
bunch of us in the block center gets
super interested in what happens now
right we just got this one piece of
information and I'm a human here sitting
here with this risk score but it's still
my task I still make the decision screen
in or screen out so do I go with what
this black box just recommended that I
do should I even go with it is that
black box actually doing any better at
being accurate or being fair than I
would have done oh we have some folks
who are helping to figure out how can we
learn that professional professor
Alexandra children Shova performed one
of the first fairness assessments for
that tool actually and along the way did
some of the math to figure out what are
the limits to how much fairness could be
improved by algorithms there is a lot
more to be done in this area we have
some work to do here and or let's say we
do think it's an improvement and it is
better an accuracy fairness though we're
so jury still out okay so if it is being
more accurate sometimes I'm gonna
overrule it and there is so much to
learn about when does that human
overrule that recommendation and is that
giving us information about way that the
AI needs to be improved we need to
better train that AI or is it giving us
information that the human doesn't
really trust that box over there and
maybe they tend to we tend to override
it in some cases rather than others and
maybe it's because I'm sitting next to a
black box professor on open data is one
of the key people who's trying to reach
into that box open it up a little bit
there's this whole algorithm in there
right that very clever algorithm and it
just gave us a risk work
a little bit more could it give us a few
key pieces what about that case made a
made the risk or be this he's got some
great methods for trying to pull some of
that stuff out but still completely
unknown is if we pull that stuff out and
show it to that decision-maker what do
they do differently and does it depend
on how we presented it alright so in
this one setting of children who are at
risk of child abuse and neglect there
are a lot of opportunities there is a
lot of work we could do here to help
make things better and this is just one
setting there are a whole bunch of other
settings high stakes medium stakes low
stakes so let's get to work we have a
lot of good to do introducing our third
and final presenter dr. Lee Branstetter
and his talk can a I make education
great again so good afternoon everybody
I'm Lee Branstetter I direct the future
of work initiative here at the block
Center and with our colleagues across
the block center
we're dedicated to leveraging Carnegie
Mellon's deep understanding of emerging
technology and its quantitative social
science acumen to help ensure that those
currently being left behind can
participate more fully and the
prosperity that technological innovation
brings now if we're going to really
succeed in achieving this incredibly
ambitious goal we're gonna have to do
something very hard we're gonna have to
make American education great again
now as hard as it may be to believe
today for more than a hundred years the
United States actually led the world in
educating its citizens now it must be
said that all the opportunities were not
available to all in these earlier
decades and centuries that certain
wasn't the case in the southern states
like Kentucky where I come from but
relative to the other advanced nations
of the time the United States did more
and it acted sooner to truly establish
mass primary education and then to truly
establish mass secondary education and
through our land-grant colleges and
public policies like the GI Bill
we expanded access to higher education
this was a singular American achievement
and it was an important force propelling
America's rise as the preeminent
industrial power in the world
now this graph comes from a great book
called the race between education and
technology written by Harvard
University's Claudia Goldin and Larry
Katz and what we see in this graph taken
from the book is that from the 1880s to
the 1960s every cohort of American
workers had more formal education than
the cohort that preceded it in the labor
market america's industrializing economy
was demanding ever more skill but
America's education system was
increasing the supply of skill even
faster than the market was demanding it
so much so that between the 1930s and
the 1960s in actually shrank even as the
economy entered a post-war boom during
that period America was winning the race
between education and technology but
unfortunately in more recent years that
long-standing rapid growth in education
and skill has slowed substantially and
the problem is that demand for higher
levels of skill has continued to grow
perhaps faster than ever as our economy
becomes ever more skill at skill and
technology intensive what that means is
that we've got a growing imbalance
between skill supply and skill demand
and that is generating an explosion of
income inequality this graph is taken
from the work of MIT economist David
autor it breaks down wage trends by
education level for American male
workers the picture for female workers
would show a very similar
of trends what we see depicted in the
scrap graph is a widening chasm between
the wage trends of our most educated
fellow citizens depicted by that top
blue graph and the wage trends of our
least educated fellow citizens depicted
by the bottom red graph for highly
educated Americans the American Dream is
working as well as it ever has for the
less educated incomes adjusted for
inflation are falling as our economy
becomes more technology intensive their
labour has just not demanded as strongly
and as always these broad-based adverse
trends tend to hit our historically
disadvantaged groups with
disproportionate intensity you know all
the skills that we might talk about
mathematics may be the most salient it's
the Gateway to the remunerative careers
of the 21st century you can't get into
or through a cs degree or a data science
degree without a high level of skill in
math and all Americans or at least most
Americans are weaker in this critical
domain than they should be
but our historically disadvantaged
groups are especially poorly prepared
for a math driven future mathematics is
the domain where test score based
differences across ethnic groups are the
largest and they're disturbingly
persistent that's what we can see in
this graph where over a generation
policy after policy and curriculum after
curriculum have been tried in an effort
to narrow that skill gap and nothing
seems to have worked and here's the even
worse news right this measures the skill
but skill gap at age 13 these gaps grow
in the high school years by grade 12 the
test score differences can be as large
as a standard deviation for
statisticians this is a canyon sized and
morally unacceptable gap and the gaps
related to parental income and education
are also large and growing over time but
fortunately learning science offers us
some hope
there's a long-standing stream of
research and learning Sciences that goes
all the way back to the 1980s that
suggests that radical changes and our
educational practices could yield huge
increases in learning outcomes back in
the early 80s learning science pioneer
Benjamin bloom and his students
conducted a series of fascinating
experiments where they randomly divided
students into a control group that
learned material in a conventional
classroom and a treatment group where
students learn the same material but
each student had a personal tutor
when the comparative learning outcomes
across these two groups they were
astounded by the results because the
average student in the tutored group
performed on these tests of
comprehension a full two standard
deviations higher than the average
student in the classroom control group
what that means is that the average
tutored student did better than 98% of
the students in the control classroom
group now I'm just gonna repeat that
again Brent emphasis right the average
student and the tutor group did better
than 98% of the students in the control
classroom group and which this suggests
is that if we could personalize
instruction we can achieve much better
learning outcomes even for those who are
currently far behind but in the early
1980s Benjamin bloom couldn't see any
technologically feasible learning
technology that could allow for
personalized instruction at a
politically acceptable cost and the
question is are we in a different place
today now at this point I want to turn
to the research of my collaborator and
colleague John Gurion who's an economist
at Northwestern University in Chicago
John and his research team have put Ben
Bloom's ideas to a very interesting
large-scale test they recruited
thousands of underperforming male
students from some of Chicago's most
challenged public schools into a study
in which students were randomly assigned
to a control group which got standard
math support and a treatment group where
each student met with a personal tutor
one tutor to two students for an
our a day every day of the academic year
and the results were amazing the
learning gains for the students in the
treatment group were so great that they
effectively narrowed the racial
achievement gap in mathematics by 1/3 in
a single year
but the cost of this intervention were
high because of its human resource
intensity Jon Gurion and his research
team figure that this intervention cost
about four thousand dollars per student
per year and of course what that means
is that the public school districts that
need this intervention the most can't
afford it now here's the question could
we use AI in combination with human
tutors to close these achievement gaps
realizing the same kinds of games as in
Jon Gurion study but at a much lower
cost now this brings me to the work of
my colleague and collaborator here at
CMU Ken Kaeding her but three decades
Ken has led a research team that has
been working to create AI driven
adaptive learning systems to accelerate
human learning especially in mathematics
the way these systems work is that they
give students problems figure out on the
basis of the mistakes student students
make what they don't know and then give
the students focused instruction in that
material until they achieve mastery and
because this is software driven the
marginal cost of giving an additional
student access to this system is very
very low now in some studies these kinds
of AI driven adaptive learning systems
have been demonstrated to generate
enormous learning gains right in one
well-done study done by the Pittsburgh
office of the RAND Corporation it was
shown that these systems double the rate
of math learning relative to a control
group and at a very low cost per student
now you can't take humans out of the
loop because the machine is never going
to be able to replicate a human beings
ability to empathize to show respect to
give encouragement and to hold students
accountable for the work that they
should be doing so could we combine
humans
and AI to eliminate these achievement
gaps
now the honest answer is that we don't
know but we have a moral obligation to
find out so here's our game plan this
spring right here in Pittsburgh we're
going to be putting combinations of
human tutors and AI in front of
underperforming students in Pittsburgh
public schools and in coming months
we're going to be doing a similar set of
studies in Chicago now these AI driven
adaptive learning systems record student
engagement with the system
second-by-second generating an
incredibly rich statistical portrait of
the students learning progress and the
students learning challenges and we can
integrate and combine these streams of
data into a digital dashboard that would
enable human tutors to understand where
each student is and what each student
needs at every point in time we can very
to to practice and machine functionality
and leverage the incredibly rich data
record being generated by the system to
observe the impact on student learning
in something close to real-time now all
this could enable us to engineer the
best most synergistic combination of
human empathy and respect and
encouragement and AI power and our best
ideas could be implemented at scale new
technology driven by artificial
intelligence and machine learning may be
placing in our hands the capability to
realize Benjamin Bloom's seemingly
impossible dream a personalized
instruction for every student at a
politically acceptable cost now much
work needs to be done before this dream
can be fully realized thanks to Keith
blocks vision and generosity we're off
to a great start we've already been able
to build on that by receiving a 1.5
million dollar grant from the Chan
Zuckerberg initiative to support this
research with that additional support
from Pittsburgh's hillman foundation
we're reaching out to the hinds
endowments but of course the resources
that we have now and the four resources
that we might
it later this year are only a fraction
of the resources that will eventually
need I expect to be working on this for
the next ten years possibly for the
remainder of my scientific career no but
if we can use the same technology that
is exacerbated income inequality to
narrow it if we can eliminate racial
achievement gaps in STEM subjects in
this generation if we could really
accelerate learning in the K through 12
grades then this will be the most
morally significant thing that I ever do
in my scientific career these are our
children this is their future they
deserve nothing less than our very best
efforts thank you very much
I hope you enjoyed these talks thank you
again for coming so please join us for
lunch upstairs
thank you again
[Applause]
yeah
give it
since we're over five 30 minutes
you want veteran students